- In 2017, hip-hop
officially surpassed rock
to become the most popular
genre in the United States,
and it's held the top spot ever since.
Rappers are the new rock stars
and are taking the headlining spots
at some of the largest music festivals.
And the sound is global
with chart-topping rap songs
in Korean, French and Spanish.
- But hip-hop was born out of
counterculture and rebellion.
Now that it's mainstream, can
artists still break the mold?
Today we're exploring alternative hip-hop,
artists that put originality first
to innovate on an
already innovative genre.
- But what does alternative even mean?
Is it something you can actually classify?
And is it fair to put
artists in a category
just for being unique?
(smooth hip-hop music)
Later, Linda and I are gonna work together
to create our own
alternative hip-hop beat.
But first, let's break down what we mean
when we say alternative music.
- Alternative hip-hop is
sort of a loose category
and not everyone agrees on its definition,
but we are using it to describe artists
who stand out from their
peers and whose originality
has made them highly influential.
Artists like Digable Planets,
MF Doom, or even Odd Future.
- To get more context
surrounding alternative hip-hop,
I sat down with Dr. Taj Frazier
from the PBS show Hip-Hop
and the Metaverse.
When you think of alternative hip-hop,
what characteristics do you
think make it alternative?
- When I think of alternative hip-hop,
I think number one, I
don't think hip-hop came up
or folks within hip-hop came
up with that terminology.
The deep thing about hip-hop, I think,
is that it's very, very
expansive and plural, you know?
So you have different subcultures
under the banner of hip-hop.
- When people think of alternative music,
they usually associate
it with rock sub-genres
like shoegaze, grunge or indie.
And that's probably because the term
originated in rock music.
The phrase alternative music
was popularized in 1979
by Terry Tolkin, a music
journalist who used alternative
to describe the underground
bands he covered.
During the '80s, the
label became a catch-all
for any music that didn't
match the commercial sounds
of mainstream rock and pop.
But there was also a
lot of experimentation
going on in hip-hop
during the '80s and '90s.
This time is called the
golden age of hip-hop.
It is known for its innovation
in production and sound.
This time also saw the mainstream rise
of gangster rap from Los Angeles
with blockbuster releases
like "Straight Outta Compton" from NWA.
And on the East Coast, hip-hop
was dominated by hardcore rap
with artists like Public
Enemy and The Notorious BIG.
But music that didn't fit into this mold
earned the moniker alternative.
- I think oftentimes what
was given kind of the name
of alt hip-hop were communities in hip-hop
that did not fit or match
the kind of boundaries
or to some degree, tropes of what people
imagine hip-hop to be.
- If you ain't have a
gun or hat to the side,
then you ain't hip-hop.
With their debut album "Bizarre Ride II,"
The Pharcyde became an
alternative hip-hop cult classic.
The lyrics showed a wackiness
and a lightheartedness
different from the gangster rap
popular in Los Angeles at the time.
The production from J-Swift
contained layers and layers
of samples with some really deep cuts
like this sax line from
an Eddie Russ song.
(saxophone music)
♪ She keeps on passin' me by ♪
- When asked why they
strayed from gangster rap,
Imani from The Pharcyde
told Acclaim magazine,
"See, the whole thing
is we're not gangsters.
"We wanted to be true to ourselves,
"and we weren't about
to fake being gangsters
"just to make rap records."
There were other artists labeled
as alternative hip-hop at this time
like Brand Nubian, De La Soul,
Digable Planets, and many more.
- So that's how alternative
hip-hop got started,
forming around the same
time as alternative rock,
to describe rap music that
didn't fall under the umbrella
of what was popular at the time.
And because this description is so broad,
there are a lot of hip-hop sub-genres
that are used in correlation
with alternative,
where conscious hip-hop describes music
with a social activism focus,
underground hip-hop often refers to music
made by indie artists.
Where anti rap focuses on
rap that's self-deprecating,
experimental hip-hop refers
to music that's more abstract.
But all of these terms are just labels
that are used interchangeably
with alternative.
And this is a perfect example
of how diving deep into sub-genres
can get really confusing.
And because hip-hop is always evolving
and some artists are so influential,
what might be considered alternative
when it's first released,
ends up becoming the norm years later.
Take the Fugees, for example,
who mix Afro-Cuban sounds
with reggae and soul
to create a truly unique
sound with the score.
♪ Oh la la la la la la la la la la la ♪
♪ Sweet thing yeah yeah ♪
- The score went on to win a Grammy
and go seven times platinum.
And because it's so
cemented in pop culture
and has been so influential
to other artists,
the music doesn't sound
as uniquely alternative as it once was.
In 1996, A Tribe Called Quest
released the jazz rap album
"Beats, Rhymes and Life"
which ended up debuting
at the number one spot
on the Billboard 200.
And this confuses things further
because with the successful
alternative groups
like Fugees and Tribe,
alternative hip-hop
suddenly became mainstream.
- Okay, but that was the '90s.
Who are the alternative
hip-hop artists of today?
First off, popular hip-hop
in the last 20 years
sounds incredibly different
from how it sounded during the golden age.
And oftentimes, unconventional production
is embraced by the mainstream.
Imagine a hip-hop fan from 1990
listening to "Lollipop" by Lil Wayne.
♪ Shawty want a thug ♪
♪ Bottles in the club ♪
- The scratchy auto-tune
singing and bubbly production
might make a fan from 1990
question if this is even hip-hop at all.
But the track went on to win the Grammy
for Best Rap Song in 2009.
Lil Wayne's song "Lollipop"
ushered in a wave
of auto-tune singing rappers
that went on to be chart toppers
like Lil Uzi Vert, Young
Thug and Coi Leray.
So if that's popular rap today,
what is alternative hip-hop like?
Today's alternative hip-hop artists
are continuing to experiment
by combining genres from across the world
to create a sound distinct
from what's trending on streaming.
Take Odd Future for example,
one of the most famous collectives
in alternative hip-hop today.
When Tyler, the Creator
released "Igor" in 2019,
he departed from the horrorcore
rap the group was known for
and leaned into funk,
neo soul, and soft rock.
Just listen to this interpolation
of Japanese soft rock
artists Tatsuro Yamashita
and his song "Gone, Gone/Thank You"
♪ Thank you for the love ♪
♪ Thank you for the joy ♪
♪ Thank you for your love ♪
♪ Thank you for the heart ♪
- Another reason a modern artist
might earn the alternative moniker
is for experimenting with
conventional hip-hop aesthetics.
For example, take Tierra Whack's music
which has been described as
experimental by Pitchfork
for its use of vocal processing
and psychedelic melodies.
♪ Heard no flow like this ♪
♪ Make you say yo excuse me miss ♪
♪ Go against me I'll beat like Swiss ♪
- To get a better understanding
of alternative hip-hop today,
I talked to Jean Deaux,
a rapper and singer who's known for mixing
a wide range of genres in her music.
I've seen websites describe
your music as alternative R&B.
What do you think of that description?
- I think alternative
is another way to say
out of the box or just non-traditional,
so I fully accept that label
because I know that I'm not making
the classic version of R&B or hip-hop
that people are used to.
So I fully embraced that all the way.
♪ 'Cause I knew I could ♪
♪ She say she need me
'cause she know it's good ♪
I definitely took some
inspiration from Santigold.
A lot of the music that
I listened to growing up
in high school like Lykke Li
and a little bit of Amy Winehouse.
A lot of rap and hip-hop, you know,
obviously Missy Elliot.
- One thing that Tierra Whack, Jean Deaux
and Tyler, the Creator all have in common
is that they all credit Missy Elliot
for being their inspiration.
In 2022, Tyler, the Creator tweeted,
"To my younger fans, go
study all her albums."
Missy Elliot broke norms when
she entered the music world
by being her unapologetic self.
She was known for constantly experimenting
and evolving her sound.
In 2022, she tweeted,
"Sophomore albums are a very
pivotal time for an artist.
"It's the best album to experiment on
"because if you play
safe, you'll be boxed in."
In Missy's sophomore
albums "Da Real World,"
she switched it up by experimenting
with the grittier, retro-futuristic sound.
The album's aesthetics pictured
a surreal sci-fi future
that championed women's empowerment.
Can you talk to me about Missy Elliot
and what she means as just an icon,
as an inspiration to you?
- Whoa, we could be here all day.
She is rock and roll, she's
hip-hop, she is classic R&B.
Everything down to the videos,
to the visual artistry,
to her kind of like breaking the mold.
I think she just got to a place where
it was undeniable, her talent,
and she kind of made room for herself.
She's always inspiring me as a artist
to just push the boundary
a little bit more
and to have that courage
to go out on a limb and take a risk.
- Missy Elliot wasn't alone.
The early 2000s were filled
with highly influential
alternative hip-hop artists
like Outkast, Doomtree and MF Doom.
- Then there's the
cross-pollination that exists
between alternative rock and hip-hop.
During the late 2000s,
indie rock saw a huge boom in popularity.
In 2009, Jay-Z was praising
the indie band Grizzly Bear
and said, "What the indie rock movement
is doing right now is really inspiring."
Since then, many rappers have collaborated
with indie rock artists
like Kendrick Lamar with Tame Impala,
Kanye with Bony Iver, and Kid
Cuddy with MGMT and Ratatat.
♪ I'm on the pursuit of
happiness and I know ♪
- [Linda] There's also
an entire wave of artists
who have been pushing past the limitations
of what hip-hop sounded like in the past.
Artists like Death Grips,
Danny Brown and Clipping.
Often called experimental hip-hop,
Clipping has blended the hip-hop sound
with avant-garde genres
like industrial and noise.
♪ Why you grab one right
by the dream space ♪
♪ Make one scream until she pray ♪
- So what exactly is alternative hip-hop?
Well, all of the artists that we mentioned
are so different from each other
that it's hard to call it a
sub-genre of hip-hop at all.
- And considering the success
that some of these artists
have seen, it's not fair to say
that it's only music
outside of the mainstream.
- Alt hip-hop often refers to
music that feels unexpected,
especially music that doesn't
fit into the common tropes
that the public has for hip-hop.
- Lil Yachty's newest album is
the perfect example of this.
The mumble rapper completely departed
from what his fans knew him for
and created a psychedelic rock album
that ended up being praised by critics.
♪ Up when it's cold ♪
♪ You call me bestie ♪
♪ Don't test me ♪
♪ I'm too sexy ♪
- [Linda] Now that we've
learned a little bit more
about what alternative hip-hop is,
Arthur and I are going
to attempt to create
our own alternative hip-hop beat.
- But when it comes to building
our alternative hip-hop track,
where do you wanna pull from?
How are we gonna put this thing together?
- So I was thinking that I would just
give you a bunch of vocal samples
and then we can make a beat out of that.
- Absolutely.
- Like a sample pack.
- Absolutely, yep, and you're
gonna step outside of your-
- [Linda] I am.
- Comfort zone with the zane
and just channel your-
- I'm gonna jump
into the zany game.
(alternative hip-hop beat)
♪ Woooo ♪
♪ Freedom ♪
- You know, also, we could
upload the track to SoundCloud
and see if any supporters or fans
wanna add a verse onto it,
see what they would do to it.
- Yeah, I'm kind of excited
to see what people do with it.
(alternative hip-hop beat)
Before you go, I wanna let you know about
Fight the Power: How Hip
Hop Changed the World,
a new PBS series hosted
by hip-hop legend Chuck D.
It's about how hip-hop
became a global movement
that spoke truth to power.
- And thank you to Dr. Taj Frazier
for joining us on this episode.
Don't forget to check out his show
Hip Hop and the Metaverse
over at PBS Voices.
Check out the links in the description.
(contemporary music)